Katrina:  那就把这个拿了
Katrina: Then take this one.
Tasha: 算了吧那把这个拿了吧
Tasha: Never mind, let's take this one.
Katrina:  好谦让哈哈哈
Katrina: So polite, hahaha.
Katrina:  还有什么
Katrina: What else?
Tasha: 我们还找
Tasha: We're still looking.
Tasha: 我们还买了个芋
Tasha: We also bought taro.
Tasha: 魔芋魔芋魔芋啊
Tasha: Konjac, konjac, konjac.
Tasha: 你们有买魔芋吗
Tasha: Did you guys buy konjac?
Lucia: 我们没有吧
Lucia: I don't think we did.
Katrina:  没有那就够了
Katrina: If not, then that's enough.
Tasha: 那就行那我把豆腐拿走
Tasha: Alright, then I'll take the tofu.
Jake:拍个照
Jake: Let's take a picture.
Katrina:  火锅调料要买蒜吗
Katrina: Do we need to buy garlic for the hotpot seasoning?
Alice: 哦蒜买了
Alice: Oh, we bought garlic.
Alice: 哦蒜有这个
Alice: Oh, we have garlic.
Jake:拍个照吧
Jake: Let's take a picture.
Alice:有这种蒜
Alice: We have this kind of garlic.
Katrina:  哈哈哈就这么草率
Katrina: Haha, so hasty.
Alice: 露出来了
Alice: It's showing.
Shure:  我们少个人
Shure: We're missing someone.
Jake:人呢
Jake: Where is everyone?
Alice:他去放豆腐了
Alice: He went to put the tofu away.
Jake:好等他回来
Jake: Alright, let's wait for him to come back.
Katrina:  哦这个是什么
Katrina: Oh, what's this?
Alice:板栗
Alice: Chestnut.
Lucia: 哎我没有见过这种板栗
Lucia: Wow, I've never seen this kind of chestnut.
Shure:  哎萝卜胡萝卜咸萝卜嫩芽子
Shure: Wow, radish, carrot, salted radish sprouts.
Shure:  香椿好韭菜嘞
Shure: Chinese toon, chives.
Lucia: 哈哈哈观察一下观察一下
Lucia: Hahaha, observe, observe.
Shure:  变异性了
Shure: It's mutated.
Alice:这还卧了个蛋呢
Alice: And there's an egg here.
Jake: 咱重建一下
Jake: Let's rebuild it.
Jake: 让他重建一下
Jake: Let him rebuild it.
Shure:  香菜
Shure: Cilantro.
Shure:  青椒哎
Shure: Green peppers, wow.
Alice: 这还是个公的
Alice: And it's a male one.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 公的哈哈哈
Lucia: A male one, hahaha.
Lucia: 发现盲点
Lucia: Found a blind spot.
Jake:哈哈哈揣俩蛋
Jake: Hahaha, carrying two eggs.
Katrina: 来吧一起
Katrina: Come on, everyone.
Tasha: 这家店没有了
Tasha: This store doesn't have it.
Alice: 荔浦鱼头
Alice: Lipu fish head.
Tasha: 这家店没有
Tasha: This store doesn't have it.
Tasha: 另一家店有
Tasha: Another store has it.
Alice: 在哪说
Alice: Where did you say?
Tasha: 说很近
Tasha: It's very close.
Tasha: 另外一家很近
Tasha: The other one is very close.
Alice: 他能调货吗
Alice: Can he transfer the goods?
Lucia: 我们刚才找到了保鲜膜
Lucia: We just found the plastic wrap.
Jake:拍拍拍个照拍个照拍个照吧
Jake: Take a photo, take a photo, take a photo.
Tasha: 他调不了
Tasha: He can't transfer it.
Lucia: 他一起吗
Lucia: Is he coming with us?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Alice:来吧
Alice: Let's go.
Tasha: 他是真的吗
Tasha: Is he for real?
Alice: 假的
Alice: No, he's fake.
Jake:来拍照了
Jake: Come on, let's take a photo.
Jake: 哎呀
Jake: Oh my.
Jake:好放回去
Jake: Alright, put it back.
Tasha: 为什么要跟一只鸡合照
Tasha: Why are we taking a photo with a chicken?
Lucia: 这是顺手的
Lucia: It's convenient.
Jake:因为看到了
Jake: Because we saw it.
Alice:这是下蛋公鸡
Alice: It's a rooster that lays eggs.
Shure: 下蛋公鸡
Shure: A rooster that lays eggs.
Shure:  公鸡下蛋
Shure: A rooster laying eggs.
Shure: 公鸡下蛋公鸡中的战斗机
Shure: A rooster laying eggs, a fighter jet among roosters.
Lucia: 出现
Lucia: Appeared.
Shure:  行大家的表情一样的僵硬
Shure: Alright, everyone's expression is equally stiff.
Shure:  我就哈哈哈放心了
Shure: I just laughed, feeling relieved.
Shure:  哈哈哈像
Shure: Haha, it's like...
Jake:相对民众
Jake: Relative to the public.
Katrina:  这好像是个动图吧
Katrina: This looks like a GIF.
Katrina:  是动图吧
Katrina: It's a GIF, right?
Katrina:  我跟你讲我们原来那个
Katrina: Let me tell you, our previous one...
Shure:  是动图我们办公室拍照
Shure: It's a GIF, we took photos in our office.
Shure:  然后有一个是原来当过idol的那种
Shure: And one of them used to be an idol.
Shure:  嗯然后就
Shure: Yeah, so...
Shure:  他跟我们就感觉不是一个涂层的
Shure: We felt like we weren't on the same level.
Shure:  你知道吗
Shure: You know?
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake:OK OK
Jake: OK, OK.
Shure:  就人家那个表情管理和装造我靠
Shure: Their expression management and styling, oh my.
Tasha: 哼哼哼哼
Tasha: Hmm, hmm, hmm.
Alice:超能
Alice: Super capable.
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Tasha: 呃有个音效你去听一下
Tasha: Uh, there's a sound effect, go listen to it.
Lucia: 没有音效是他模仿的
Lucia: There are no sound effects, he's just mimicking them.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Tasha: 你给每个人都看一眼
Tasha: Show it to everyone.
Tasha: 哈哈哈然后我们去买保鲜膜
Tasha: Hahaha, then let's go buy some cling film.
Alice:哼哼哼哼
Alice: Hehehehe
Katrina: 弹舌吗
Katrina: Are you clicking your tongue?
Alice:你去学俄语吧
Alice: You should learn Russian.
Tasha: 买个羽绒吧
Tasha: Let's buy a down jacket.
Katrina: 我不会
Katrina: I can't do it.
Tasha: 还有个薄荷
Tasha: There's also some mint.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 不一定能买的到
Tasha: We might not be able to buy it.
Tasha: 然后就没了
Tasha: That's all.
Shure:  我原来也不会
Shure: I couldn't do it before either.
Shure:  我记得有一天滑个滑板
Shure: I remember one day I was skateboarding.
Tasha:奶粉也不一定
Tasha: Even milk powder isn't certain.
Shure:  然后一下就会了
Shure: Then suddenly I could do it.
Jake:再拍一次管理一下
Jake: Let's shoot again and manage this.
Jake: 能管理的了吗
Jake: Can it be managed?
Shure:  管理不了
Shure: It can't be managed.
Lucia: 管理一下管理一下
Lucia: Manage it, manage it.
Jake: 管理一下好
Jake: Manage it, okay.
Shure:  怎么怎么管理一下
Shure: How are we supposed to manage it?
Jake:不知道啊
Jake: I don't know.
Shure:  就是看着像正常人类一点
Shure: Just try to look more like a normal human.
Katrina: 禁止禁止 10秒钟
Katrina: Prohibit, prohibit for 10 seconds.
Jake: 那很难那很难
Jake: That's really hard.
Jake: 这回来个10秒的
Jake: This time, let's do 10 seconds.
Shure:  10秒
Shure: 10 seconds.
Katrina:  10秒他保持不了10秒进去
Katrina: He can't hold it for 10 seconds.
Jake: 那就酝酿一会
Jake: Then let's prepare a bit.
Tasha: 呵呵
Tasha: Hehe.
Jake: 你的音效声音
Jake: Your sound effect.
Lucia: 看大家的管理成果
Lucia: Look at everyone's management results.
Tasha: 表情管理成果吗
Tasha: Expression management results?
Jake: 看一看
Jake: Let's see.
Katrina:  可以无所谓
Katrina: It's okay, whatever.
Alice: 鸦雀无声
Alice: Silence.
Shure: 更僵了
Shure: It's even more awkward.
Lucia: 鸦雀无声
Lucia: Silence.
Jake:鸦雀无声
Jake: Silence
Jake:没事
Jake: It's okay
Alice:走吧
Alice: Let's go
Lucia: 还缺啥吗
Lucia: Are we missing anything?
Katrina:  还缺啥吗
Katrina: Are we missing anything?
Tasha: 还缺保鲜膜
Tasha: We still need plastic wrap
Tasha: 你们买一下
Tasha: Can you guys buy it?
Katrina: 买了
Katrina: Bought it
Lucia: 买了我们买了保鲜膜
Lucia: We bought plastic wrap
Lucia: 保鲜膜买了
Lucia: Got the plastic wrap
Lucia: 找到了
Lucia: Found it
Tasha: 还有什么
Tasha: Anything else?
Tasha: 蛋挞皮
Tasha: Tart shells
Alice:荔浦芋头
Alice: Lipu taro
Tasha: 芋头没有
Tasha: No taro
Shure:  杨老板头大了
Shure: Jake is having a headache
Alice:没了
Alice: No more
Tasha: 薄荷买了吗
Tasha: Did we get mint?
Katrina:  没有买薄荷哎
Katrina: We didn't buy mint
Alice: 没有薄荷可能
Alice: Probably no mint
Tasha: 是没有薄荷
Tasha: There's no mint
Jake:没有这些都很便宜听起来
Jake: These all sound cheap
Jake: 是吧
Jake: Right?
Shure:  知道什么叫聚沙成塔
Shure: Do you know what "gathering sand to build a tower" means?
Jake:哼哼哼哼
Jake: Ha ha ha
Shure:  压死骆驼的最后一根稻草吗
Shure: The last straw that breaks the camel's back?
Tasha: 蛋挞皮
Tasha: Tart shells
Katrina: 薄荷蛋挞皮薄荷
Katrina: Mint, tart shells, mint
Jake: 最后一个蛋挞皮
Jake: The last tart shell
Lucia: 最后一个蛋挞皮
Lucia: The last tart shell
Alice: 实在没有薄荷
Alice: There's really no mint
Alice:要不然下楼摘点叶子吧
Alice: How about we go downstairs and pick some leaves?
Shure:  咱们去那个那什么
Shure: Let's go to that place
Shure:  买一盆新的就行
Shure: And buy a new pot of mint
Alice: 把我们那花剪点当装饰
Alice: Let's cut some flowers from our place to use as decoration
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No
Alice:你在找啥
Alice: What are you looking for?
Alice: 蛋挞皮
Alice: Tart shells
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Right
Alice:这蛋挞
Alice: This egg tart
Shure:  烘焙区是不是在前面
Shure: Is the bakery section up ahead?
Tasha: 那吗
Tasha: Is it?
Shure:  好像是吧我刚才看到烘焙俩字
Shure: I think so, I just saw the word "bakery."
Tasha: 烘焙区是烘口的
Tasha: The bakery section is for baking.
Tasha: 对不是这儿
Tasha: Yeah, it's not here.
Alice:怎么了
Alice: What's wrong?
Tasha: 他说烘焙区里面有烘蛋挞
Tasha: He said there are egg tarts in the bakery section.
Alice:有熟的
Alice: They have cooked ones.
Shure:  嚯跟后台要
Shure: Wow, ask the back kitchen for them.
Tasha: 服务台在那吗
Tasha: Is the service desk over there?
Alice:啥呀
Alice: What?
Tasha: 蛋挞皮
Tasha: Egg tart crusts.
Tasha: 真的好过分啊
Tasha: This is really too much.
Alice:怎么了
Alice: What's wrong?
Tasha: 在吃伞底下就应该喝椰子
Tasha: Under the umbrella, you should be drinking coconut.
Alice:蛋挞皮能用啥替代呢
Alice: What can we use to substitute egg tart crusts?
Tasha: 没有东西能替代
Tasha: Nothing can replace them.
Alice: 馄饨皮
Alice: Wonton wrappers.
Alice: 馄饨皮刷蛋液行吗
Alice: Can we brush egg wash on wonton wrappers?
Alice: 哇他们家还出这个了
Alice: Wow, they even have this.
Tasha: 有吗咦
Tasha: Do they? Hmm.
Tasha: 是什么牌子
Tasha: What brand is it?
Alice:没有
Alice: They don't have it.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thank you.
Tasha: 没有没有
Tasha: Nope, they don't.
Lucia: 谢谢好像有那么一点点糊
Lucia: Thanks, it seems a bit burnt.
Tasha: 啊没有那就只
Tasha: Oh, if not, you can only buy it online.
Tasha: 能在网上买了
Tasha: You can only buy it online.
Alice:这是什么柜子啊
Alice: What kind of cabinet is this?
Alice: 免费领菜
Alice: Free vegetables.
Tasha: 你看就是今天可以免费领的区
Tasha: Look, this area is for free vegetables today.
Alice:有我们要的吗
Alice: Do they have what we want?
Alice:嗯这是大馒头
Alice: Hmm, these are big buns.
Alice:吃火锅需要面吗
Alice: Do we need noodles for hot pot?
Tasha: 呃你有会员吗
Tasha: Uh, do you have a membership?
Tasha: 要x会员
Tasha: You need an X membership.
Alice:x会员好像不是吧
Alice: Isn't it an X membership?
Tasha: 黄金会员钻石会员的主口
Tasha: Gold membership, diamond membership.
Tasha: 普通会员拉倒
Tasha: Regular membership won't do.
Tasha: 要298一年
Tasha: It's 298 per year.
Alice:那种的
Alice: That kind?
Tasha: 不然我天天都领
Tasha: Otherwise, I'd get it every day.
Tasha: 没有问过服务台了
Tasha: I haven't asked the service desk yet.
Katrina:  薄荷和那个什么芋泥
Katrina: Mint and that, uh, taro thing.
Katrina:  还有那个蛋挞皮都没有
Katrina: And there's no tart crust either.
Alice: 对别的都可以
Alice: Right, everything else is fine.
Tasha: 但是蛋挞液自己做的话
Tasha: But if you make the tart filling yourself,
Tasha: 要旺仔牛奶就行了
Tasha: Just use Wangzai milk.
Lucia: 啊我知道了
Lucia: Ah, I got it.
Lucia: 这个是用来送打包外卖的
Lucia: This is for takeout packaging.
Lucia: 刚才看到一个袋子过去
Lucia: I just saw a bag go by.
Lucia: 我终于知道它是干什么的了
Lucia: I finally know what it's for.
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes.
Katrina:  自己做麻烦吗
Katrina: Is it troublesome to make it yourself?
Tasha: 不麻烦
Tasha: Not troublesome.
Jake:他就是他
Jake: He is who he is.
Jake:走几步很难吗
Jake: Is it hard to take a few steps?
Alice: 要放淡奶油吧
Alice: You need to add heavy cream, right?
Lucia: 可能是
Lucia: Maybe.
Tasha: 对淡奶油炼乳白砂糖蛋液
Tasha: Yes, heavy cream, condensed milk, white sugar, and egg mixture.
Lucia: 给大家造成一种高科技的错觉
Lucia: It gives everyone an illusion of high-tech.
Jake:好的
Jake: Got it.
Tasha: 蛋蛋液就行了
Tasha: Just the egg mixture.
Tasha: 还有旺仔牛奶
Tasha: And Wangzai milk.
Alice: 蛋挞皮的话那个
Alice: As for the tart crust, that...
Lucia: 但实际上这玩意很像蒸汽朋克时代那种话筒
Lucia: But actually, this thing looks like a steampunk microphone.
Alice:蛋挞皮能自己做吗蛋挞皮是不是得
Alice: Can you make the tart crust yourself? Don't you need...
Lucia: 可以外送了
Lucia: It can be delivered.
Alice: 对闪溢的
Alice: Right, like the sparkling one.
Tasha: 但是我想要
Tasha: But I want to...
Tasha: 叫什么奥昆
Tasha: What's it called, Oakun?
Tasha: 奥昆
Tasha: Oakun.
Jake: 这是什么呀
Jake: What is that?
Tasha: 呃精品
Tasha: Uh, boutique.
Jake:草履虫
Jake: Paramecium.
Lucia: 我就是这么以为的
Lucia: That's what I thought too.
Katrina: 就是你对牌子有要求吗
Katrina: Do you care about the brand?
Jake: 嗯大细菌
Jake: Hmm, big bacteria.
Tasha: 蛋挞皮
Tasha: Tart crust.
Jake: 大肠杆菌
Jake: E. coli
Shure:  对大肠杆菌
Shure: Yes, E. coli
Shure:  大肠杆菌
Shure: E. coli
Katrina: 你那指甲还挺好看的
Katrina: Your nails look pretty nice
Lucia: 撒了那种
Lucia: Sprinkled that kind
Lucia: 就是生日蛋糕上面那种小糖碎的草莓
Lucia: Like the small sugar bits on a birthday cake
Katrina: 是裸色吗
Katrina: Is it nude color?
Tasha: 刚掉了 爬墙
Tasha: It just fell off while climbing the wall
Katrina: 我我我特想抠
Katrina: I really, really want to scratch it
Jake:啊这甜甜圈
Jake: Ah, this donut
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: You know what?
Jake:吃了一口
Jake: Took a bite
Katrina: 如果我镶钻了
Katrina: If I had diamonds on it
Tasha: 我也是我我刚做的
Tasha: Me too, I just got them done
Shure:  这后面是一个姜饼人
Shure: There's a gingerbread man at the back
Shure:  所以就是没有
Shure: So there isn't
Alice:没有只能外卖买了吧
Alice: We'll have to order delivery then
Jake:是一个
Jake: It's a
Shure:  只能外卖买了
Shure: We'll have to order delivery
Jake: 猫头鹰啊
Jake: An owl
Lucia: 姜饼
Lucia: Gingerbread
Jake:姜饼人
Jake: Gingerbread man
Tasha: 我们买个旺仔牛奶就走吧
Tasha: Let's just buy some Wangzai milk and go
Jake:人呢
Jake: Where are they?
Jake:姜饼猫头鹰怎么了
Jake: What's up with the gingerbread owl?
Katrina:  旺仔牛奶
Katrina: Wangzai milk
Tasha: 旺仔牛奶
Tasha: Wangzai milk
Tasha: 走,go
Tasha: Let's go
Tasha: 然后就没了
Tasha: And then it's gone
Jake: 好在哪里
Jake: Okay, where is it?
Tasha: 在哪里牛奶区吧
Tasha: Where is the milk section?
Katrina: 好像没有逛到旺仔牛奶
Katrina: Seems like we didn't browse to the Wangzai milk
啊：好困
Ah: So sleepy
Tasha: 他们家不一定有旺仔牛奶
Tasha: They might not have Wangzai milk here
Katrina: 人 类是这样的
Katrina: Humans are like this
Katrina:  因为人活着累
Katrina: Because life is tiring
Shure:  洗了算了
Shure: Just wash it off then
Katrina:  哎呀对不起
Katrina: Ah, sorry
Alice:哎呦哦没事
Alice: Oh, it's okay
Lucia: 没有
Lucia: No problem
Shure: 完了追尾了
Shure: Oh no, we rear-ended someone.
Alice: 因为他们家有自自营的那种牛奶
Alice: Because their family has their own dairy business.
Lucia: 算了吧那就走吧
Lucia: Forget it, let's just go.
Katrina:  也没有吗
Katrina: They don't have it either?
Katrina:  没有就不一样了
Katrina: If they don't have it, it's different.
Alice:对就不一定有旺仔的
Alice: Right, they might not have Wangzai products.
Katrina:  是不是跟他们有品牌竞争啊
Katrina: Is it because they have brand competition?
Katrina: 利益冲突
Katrina: Conflict of interest.
Tasha: 因为他们有那个自营的
Tasha: Because they have their own products.
Katrina: 自营嘛对
Katrina: Yeah, their own products.
Shure:  都是他们的竞品哦
Shure: All of them are competing products.
Lucia: 所以盒马对标当然是
Lucia: So Hema's benchmark is of course...
Katrina: 全员竞品啊
Katrina: Everyone's a competing product.
Katrina: 汇源果汁也没有
Katrina: Huiyuan juice is also not there.
Tasha: 你是因为镜头在录
Tasha: Is it because the camera is recording?
Katrina: 桃汁也没有
Katrina: Peach juice is also not there.
Jake:没有那你为什么要打我
Jake: If it's not there, why did you hit me?
Shure: 那种山姆吧我感觉
Shure: It's like Sam's Club, I feel.
Katrina: 自营为什么不出桃汁呢
Katrina: Why don't they produce their own peach juice?
Jake:为了把你丢这个钻石丢在我的身上啊
Jake: To make you throw this diamond at me.
Lucia: 如果自营有同品类的话会形成竞争而且这样他们可以降低成本
Lucia: If they have their own similar products, it would create competition and lower costs.
Jake:就是你打我然后丢了钻石
Jake: So you hit me and then lost the diamond.
Lucia: 不管是制造成本还是
Lucia: Whether it's manufacturing costs or...
Katrina:  嗯还有听你讲经济学原理
Katrina: Yeah, listening to you talk about economic principles.
Tasha: 这里有汉堡
Tasha: Here's a burger.
Shure:  好像现在那个美团也在搞
Shure: It seems like Meituan is also doing it now.
Shure:  那个小象超市但是他目前都是线上的
Shure: That Xiaoxiang supermarket, but it's all online for now.
Jake:真的可以做哎
Jake: It could really work.
Tasha: 可以多要做汉堡
Tasha: You can make more burgers.
Katrina: 啊我刚看到了
Katrina: Ah, I just saw it.
Shure:  而且
Shure: Also...
Shure:  咱们那个地方还不在那个小象
Shure: Our place isn't in Xiaoxiang's...
Shure:  超市配送区
Shure: Supermarket delivery area.
Lucia: 如果他能掌控整个供应链的话
Lucia: If they control the whole supply chain...
Lucia: 就能把成本降到最低
Lucia: They can minimize costs.
Lucia: 但是像京东什么物流这些都是自己做的嘛
Lucia: But like JD.com, they handle their own logistics.
Shure:  而且盒马他们那个配送费你满39
Shure: And Hema's delivery fee is waived if you spend over 39.
Shure:  他就免配送
Shure: So it's actually very convenient.
Shure:  就是其实很 方便
Shure: It's really convenient.
Katrina: 我们自己扫
Katrina: We scan ourselves.
Alice:嗯？
Alice: Huh?
Alice: 他人呢
Alice: Where is everyone?
Alice:开始结账了吗
Alice: Have they started checking out?
Lucia: 那里有一个取消交易
Lucia: There's a cancel transaction button over there.
Tasha: 借的会员
Tasha: Borrowed membership.
Jake: 借的会员
Jake: Borrowed membership.
Tasha: 那肯定要借嘛
Tasha: Of course, it needs to be borrowed.
Shure:  杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Jake: 哎
Jake: Yeah?
Shure:  到您了
Shure: It's your turn.
Jake: 到已经扫完了
Jake: I've already scanned everything.
Shure:  没有得先扫会员码
Shure: No, you need to scan the membership code first.
Jake: 哦那我也没有啊
Jake: Oh, but I don't have it.
Alice: 普通会员不就行了吗
Alice: Isn't a regular membership enough?
Shure:  不是就必须
Shure: No, it has to be...
Katrina: 你们谁有会员
Katrina: Who has a membership?
Alice:普通会员就可以了
Alice: A regular membership will do.
Tasha: 找88会员
Tasha: Find an 88 membership.
Shure:  我来吧
Shure: I'll do it.
Tasha: 行吧
Tasha: Okay.
Katrina:  88VIP有盒马吗
Katrina: Does 88VIP work with Hema?
Tasha: 找88会呃不是88折盒马哦
Tasha: Look for 88... oh no, it's not 88% off at Hema.
Jake: 哦所以你有是吧
Jake: Oh, so you have it, right?
Tasha: 呃我我呃等一下
Tasha: Uh, I... wait a minute.
Jake: 修硕有还是
Jake: Does Shure have it?
Lucia: 我甚至没有盒马APP
Lucia: I don't even have the Hema app.
Shure:  我有盒马APP
Shure: I have the Hema app.
Jake:我也我也没有我也没有
Jake: I don't, I don't have it either.
Shure:  但我好像卡里没有那么多钱
Shure: But I don't think I have enough money in my account.
Tasha: 对我我还有优惠券
Tasha: Yeah, I also have coupons.
Alice: 你点不到啊
Alice: You can't find it?
Lucia: 盒马是必须要用APP才能结账的
Lucia: You need to use the Hema app to check out.
Lucia: 我刚回国的时候跟我爸逛了一趟
Lucia: When I first came back to China, I went shopping with my dad.
Lucia: 发现只能用APP结账
Lucia: I found out you can only check out with the app.
Alice:福利
Alice: What a perk.
Lucia: 我就出去了什么也没买
Lucia: I just left without buying anything.
Jake:哈哈哈那你要坐两个拖车的话
Jake: Hahaha, so if you need to take two carts...
Jake: 然后怎么放回去
Jake: Then how do you put them back?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Lucia: 就是因为那天拿的东西其实也不太行
Lucia: Because the stuff we got that day wasn't that great either.
Jake:打的东西还行
Jake: What you did was pretty good.
Jake:哦OK
Jake: Oh, OK.
Alice:哎为什么用不了呢
Alice: Hey, why isn't it working?
Shure: 杨老板要不给给你弄一个
Shure: Jake, do you want me to fix it for you?
Shure:  好啊支付宝有吧
Shure: Alright, do you have Alipay?
Jake:好
Jake: Sure.
Jake: 支付宝有啊
Jake: I do have Alipay.
Shure:  那支付宝也行
Shure: Then Alipay is fine.
Shure:  支付宝里有二维码
Shure: There's a QR code in Alipay.
Jake: 支付宝还是有
Jake: Alipay still works.
Alice: 我打开APP
Alice: I'll open the app.
Alice: 不知道为什么点不了二维码
Alice: I don't know why I can't click the QR code.
Alice: 是不是因为我们开着那个啥的
Alice: Is it because we have something else open?
Alice: 哦但你一关那个啥不就停那啥了吗
Alice: Oh, but if you close that, it would stop, right?
Alice:把我家地址录上了没关系吧
Alice: I recorded my home address, is that okay?
Lucia: 他们会处理好像
Lucia: They will handle it, I think.
Tasha: 有有有有
Tasha: Yes, yes, yes.
Jake:对回头会看一眼
Jake: Yes, we'll check it later.
Jake: 那个看一眼这谁的手机
Jake: Whose phone is this?
Katrina: 这谁的手机他的吗
Katrina: Whose phone is this, his?
Jake: 这个压力还是挺大的
Jake: This is quite stressful.
Jake: 把你们的片都看一遍
Jake: I'll review all your videos.
Lucia: 我加油
Lucia: I'll cheer up.
Katrina: 你用试试
Katrina: You give it a try.
Shure: 减20块钱
Shure: Save 20 yuan.
Alice:不过没关系
Alice: But it's alright.
Lucia: 因为我觉得我看手机的时候
Lucia: Because when I look at my phone,
Katrina: 这样也可以啊
Katrina: This works too.
Lucia: 肯定会看到我家地址
Lucia: I'll definitely see my home address.
Lucia: 或者之类的类似的东西
Lucia: Or similar stuff.
Tasha: 我一打开APP就默认我家地址
Tasha: As soon as I open the app, it defaults to my home address.
Tasha: 我的外送地址
Tasha: My delivery address.
Katrina: 不是你有会员吗
Katrina: Don't you have a membership?
Lucia: 我也是
Lucia: Me too.
Lucia: 我今天打开淘宝查材料包的时候也是
Lucia: When I opened Taobao today to check the material packages, same thing.
Katrina:  也就用你的呗
Katrina: Then just use yours.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Katrina:  用你的然后让他给你报呗
Katrina: Use yours and let him reimburse you.
Lucia: 辛苦了哈哈
Lucia: Thank you, haha.
Jake: 确实
Jake: Indeed.
Katrina:  来吧
Katrina: Come on.
Alice: 开始
Alice: Start.
Jake: 发生了什么
Jake: What happened?
Shure:  没事可以开始了
Shure: It's okay, you can start now.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 我们要不要再拿一个车过来
Lucia: Should we get another car?
Shure:  再拿一个道吧
Shure: Get another lane.
Jake: 插个电吧
Jake: Plug it in.
Alice: 我也是吧
Alice: Me too.
Alice: 我能看到
Alice: I can see it.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Okay.
Jake:咱咱眼睛插个电吧
Jake: Let's plug in the eyes.
Jake:别别最后挂掉了
Jake: No, no, don't hang up now.
Alice:来给我吧
Alice: Give it to me.
Jake: 你的电还在吗
Jake: Is your battery still good?
Jake:还有挺好挺好
Jake: Still good, great.
Alice:我的电还在
Alice: My battery is still good.
Jake: 我们这些东西怎么带走啊
Jake: How do we carry all this stuff?
Tasha: 袋子装
Tasha: In bags.
Jake:袋子哦
Jake: In bags, huh.
Lucia: 有种给自己脑子接口一样的感觉
Lucia: Feels like connecting an interface to my brain.
Shure: 先扫俩袋子然后边扫边装
Shure: First scan a couple of bags, then fill them as you go.
Tasha: 就跟自己是个AI机器人给自己充电
Tasha: It's like being an AI robot charging itself.
Katrina: 在哪扫袋子
Katrina: Where do we scan the bags?
Jake:给充电对对对电没了
Jake: Yeah, charge it up, the battery's dead.
Tasha: 你怎么可以
Tasha: How could you?
Alice:放你包里吗先
Alice: Should I put it in your bag first?
Tasha: 可以
Tasha: Sure.
Jake: 我可熟练了
Jake: I'm really good at this.
Jake: 没有人比我更熟练
Jake: No one is better than me.
Lucia: 哇我去看一下
Lucia: Wow, I'll go check it out.
Jake:我来帮您来
Jake: Let me help you.
Tasha: 好谢谢你
Tasha: Okay, thanks.
Jake:我觉得自己这确实有点难
Jake: I think this is really quite difficult.
Jake:多少拿着点啊
Jake: Hold it, okay?
Jake:疼吗
Jake: Does it hurt?
Jake:好行
Jake: Alright, good.
Tasha: 好了吗
Tasha: Is it done?
Lucia: 我们可以把这个袋先扫一下
Lucia: We can scan this bag first.
Lucia: 他说要扫一下然后好吧拿了俩
Lucia: He said to scan it first, then okay, got two.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Okay
Tasha: 好哎好了
Tasha: All right, done
Jake:好了啊
Jake: It's done, huh
Tasha: 好了
Tasha: Done
Jake:可以
Jake: Okay
Tasha: 就跟打针一样
Tasha: Just like getting a shot
Jake:哈哈哈他妈他妈
Jake: Hahaha, his mom, his mom
Lucia: 然后就可以往里走
Lucia: Then we can go inside
Jake: 好了哈哈
Jake: Okay, haha
Lucia: 怎么感觉好像两个袋也不够
Lucia: Why does it feel like two bags aren't enough
Tasha: 可以先结账
Tasha: We can check out first
Tasha: 这个已经优惠10块钱了
Tasha: This one already has a 10 yuan discount
Katrina:  先结一部分是吗
Katrina: Pay part of it first, right?
Tasha: 对然后再扫
Tasha: Yes, then scan again
Tasha: 然后还有两张券
Tasha: And there are two more coupons
Katrina:  可以可以
Katrina: Okay, okay
Jake: 他是什么
Jake: What is it?
Jake: 每100每500省10块
Jake: Save 10 yuan for every 100 or 500?
Tasha: 不是我的红包券好不好
Tasha: No, my coupon, okay?
Tasha: 我在牺牲我自己
Tasha: I'm sacrificing myself
Shure:  哈哈哦哦
Shure: Haha, oh oh
Jake:哦哦可以感感谢老板捐10块钱
Jake: Oh oh, thanks, boss, for donating 10 yuan
Katrina: 那就先付吧
Katrina: Then let's pay first
Jake: 好这是10块钱捐赠是吧
Jake: Okay, so this is a 10 yuan donation, right?
Jake: 哎这些扫没扫呢
Jake: Hey, have these been scanned?
Shure:  哎怎么扫
Shure: Hey, how to scan
Jake:应该怎么扫阿里pay吗
Jake: How should we scan it, Alipay?
Lucia: 都是扫过的呢
Lucia: These have all been scanned
Shure:  都是扫过的
Shure: All scanned
Lucia: 这个车里的车还没扫呢
Lucia: The stuff in this cart hasn't been scanned
Lucia: 那边应该都扫过了
Lucia: That side should be all scanned
Lucia: 那这呃这俩袋子也不够好像
Lucia: These two bags don't seem to be enough
Katrina:  行吧再再要一个袋子是吧
Katrina: Okay, should we get another bag?
Alice:心痛
Alice: Heartache
Tasha: 真的能付成功吗可以吧
Tasha: Can we really pay successfully? It should be okay, right?
Tasha: 哦可以的
Tasha: Oh, it works
Katrina:  我们怎么提回去
Katrina: How are we gonna carry this back?
Jake:100刀100新币
Jake: 100 dollars, 100 SGD
Shure:  100新币对
Shure: 100 SGD, right
Jake:一车就100新币
Jake: A cart is 100 SGD
Shure:  不到100新币
Shure: Less than 100 Singapore dollars.
Jake: 我每次一塑料袋100新币
Jake: I spend 100 Singapore dollars each time on a plastic bag.
Shure:  杨老板就是大气
Shure: Jake, you're so generous.
Lucia: 没到一车呢
Lucia: It's not even a whole cart yet.
Lucia: 这边才装了
Lucia: We just started loading here.
Jake: OK OK
Jake: OK OK.
Jake: 那可能是400金币
Jake: That might be 400 gold coins.
Jake: 我估计
Jake: I guess.
Tasha: 这个结过账的
Tasha: This one has been checked out.
Lucia: 对这这里也都结了
Lucia: Yes, this one has been checked out too.
Lucia: 这里这里好像还没结吧
Lucia: Here, here hasn't been checked out yet, right?
Katrina:  放台上没有
Katrina: Did you put it on the table?
Katrina:  没有放台上
Katrina: It’s not on the table.
Alice:这怎么放呢
Alice: How should we place this?
Lucia: 先把这的都挪到这
Lucia: Move all these over here first.
Jake:再来一个车
Jake: Get another cart.
Jake: 我再来一辆车
Jake: I'll get another cart.
Jake: 再来一辆车
Jake: Get another cart.
Jake:不用用了哦OK好嘞
Jake: No need, oh OK, alright.
Lucia: 就把这个都挪过来然后
Lucia: Move all of these over and then...
Lucia: 那边装完的放到这个车里
Lucia: Put the ones that are done over there into this cart.
Katrina: 就是没结是吗
Katrina: So this one hasn't been checked out, right?
Jake:结账要先下载好盒马APP才能结账
Jake: To check out, you need to download the Hema app first.
Katrina: 那就交换一下
Katrina: Then let's swap it out.
Katrina: 在那边装袋吧
Katrina: Pack it over there.
Tasha: 新加坡没有盒马是吗
Tasha: Does Singapore not have Hema?
Jake: 应该没有
Jake: I don't think so.
Jake: 我探索的也不多
Jake: I haven't explored much there.
Jake: 那新加坡那边是什么样的超市
Jake: What are the supermarkets like in Singapore?
Lucia: 就这种天生纤维的这种
Lucia: They have these natural fiber ones.
Katrina: 呀感觉还需要袋子
Katrina: Feels like we still need more bags.
Lucia: 全食吗
Lucia: Whole Foods?
Jake:不是就是他们有一家fire price
Jake: No, they have one called FairPrice.
Jake: 应该是政府给了很多补贴的
Jake: I think the government subsidized it a lot.
Jake: 哦叫fire price
Jake: Oh, it's called FairPrice.
Jake: 很便宜对对对
Jake: It's very cheap, yes, yes, yes.
Lucia: 这个线老是让我弄得很奇怪
Lucia: This wire keeps getting weird on me.
Jake:哎我帮你
Jake: Let me help you.
Jake:要不就是这个放你后面
Jake: Maybe put this behind you.
Shure:  再来一个袋
Shure: Get another bag.
Shure:  你好你好
Shure: Hello, hello.
Shure:  再来一个袋
Shure: Give me another bag.
Lucia: 有点卷插头
Lucia: The plug is a bit tangled.
Tasha: 结过账了
Tasha: I've already paid.
Katrina:  对方台上都是结过账
Katrina: Everyone at the table has paid.
Lucia: 给他弄直一点
Lucia: Straighten it out a bit.
Lucia: 啊对
Lucia: Ah, right.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Lucia: 要不然好像我动着动着
Lucia: Otherwise, it feels like I'm moving around and...
Lucia: 他就快要把我缠起来了
Lucia: It's going to wrap around me.
Katrina: 哈真买了很多饮料
Katrina: Haha, you really bought a lot of drinks.
Jake:这个是久经验证的插电姿势
Jake: This is a well-tested way to plug it in.
Jake:对其实在后面绕过来最好后面贴个胶
Jake: Actually, it's best to loop it from the back and tape it.
Lucia: 你是做过多少次这样类似的实验了
Lucia: How many times have you done this kind of experiment?
Jake: 对这个1月份到的
Jake: This arrived in January.
Jake: 我带着这个到处
Jake: I've been carrying it around.
Jake: 就看比赛啊
Jake: Watching competitions and all.
Jake: 进城都带着这个东西
Jake: I bring this even when I go to the city.
Jake: 哦看比赛还可以那
Jake: Oh, watching competitions with it is fine.
Lucia: 那会把比赛整个
Lucia: Does it record the whole competition?
Lucia: 记录建模下来吗
Lucia: And model it?
Jake: 这个不会
Jake: No, it doesn't.
Jake:这个不会这个就版权的问题
Jake: No, it doesn't. That's a copyright issue.
Jake: 只能扫扫进场的仪式
Jake: It can only scan the entrance ceremony.
Tasha: 那
Tasha: Then...
Tasha: 那看电影的时候能把电影记下来吗
Tasha: Can it record movies when watching them?
Alice:这个放别的地
Alice: Put this somewhere else.
Lucia: 那也不行吧
Lucia: That won't work either.
Lucia: 也牵涉版权哦
Lucia: It's also a copyright issue.
Lucia: 这不就是枪版
Lucia: That would be a bootleg.
Jake: 哈哈哈这就是枪版
Jake: Hahaha, that's a bootleg.
Lucia: 3D枪版
Lucia: A 3D bootleg.
Jake:这就是枪版
Jake: That's a bootleg.
Lucia: 坐在电影院的体验
Lucia: It's like sitting in the cinema.
Jake: 哎是的是的
Jake: Yes, exactly.
Jake:我带一个这个进去给你打出来
Jake: I can take one of these in and print it out for you.
Alice:放点轻的吧
Alice: Play something lighter.
Jake:哈哈我就这个装备进电影院
Jake: Haha, I'll just take this equipment into the cinema.
Alice:我觉得这个有点够呛了
Alice: I think this is a bit too much.
Katrina: 放点小饮料吧
Katrina: Let's put in some small drinks.
Lucia: 感觉很酷炫的样子
Lucia: Looks pretty cool.
Alice:这拖着底抱
Alice: This is dragging the bottom.
Katrina:  这什么呀
Katrina: What is this?
Shure:  再来一个
Shure: One more time.
Jake: 感觉两条腿都要断
Jake: Feels like both my legs are going to break.
Shure:  再去拿两个袋
Shure: Go get two more bags.
小Lucia: 再来两个袋
Little Lucia: Get two more bags.
Jake: 耍赖吗
Jake: Are you cheating?
Jake: 这边有冰块
Jake: There's ice over here.
Jake: 保鲜冰块
Jake: Preserving ice.
Jake: 保鲜冰块能吃吗
Jake: Can we eat preserving ice?
Alice: 呃不能吃
Alice: Uh, no, you can't.
Jake: 好吧好吧好吧
Jake: Alright, alright, alright.
Tasha: 但是你可以带
Tasha: But you can bring it.
Tasha: 呃也不用吧
Tasha: Uh, never mind.
Jake: 我们用不着吧
Jake: We don't need it, right?
Jake: 我们
Jake: We...
Katrina:  要多少钱拿
Katrina: How much to take it?
Jake: 编辑一下
Jake: Edit it a bit.
Lucia: 矫正视力
Lucia: Correcting vision.
Katrina: 你那个券是多少
Katrina: How much is your coupon?
Katrina: 满多少
Katrina: What's the minimum spend?
Jake: 我们视力都有问题
Jake: We all have vision problems.
Alice:500 500
Alice: 500, 500.
Jake: 就是我们6个人一样的问题
Jake: All six of us have the same problem.
Alice:这个结过了吗
Alice: Is this settled?
Jake: 病友
Jake: Fellow patients.
Katrina:  都结过了
Katrina: It's all settled.
Jake: 呃对
Jake: Uh, yeah.
Alice: 放点放点占位置的
Alice: Put some, put some to take up space.
Jake: 对呃这是全景
Jake: Yeah, uh, this is a panoramic view.
Lucia: 拍vlog
Lucia: Filming a vlog.
Tasha: 博主探店的博主
Tasha: Blogger exploring the store.
Jake: 博主博主
Jake: Blogger, blogger.
Jake: 对对6人博主
Jake: Yeah, six-person blogger.
Jake: 博主探店
Jake: Blogger exploring the store.
Katrina:  博主能送两个菜吗
Katrina: Can the blogger give us two dishes?
Jake: 对网上见就是好吧
Jake: Yeah, see you online, alright.
Jake: 哈哈哈自己开个超市是吧
Jake: Hahaha, opening our own supermarket, right?
Jake: 自己开个盒马
Jake: Opening our own Hema.
Lucia: 这个也做美食
Lucia: This is also a culinary creation.
Lucia: 哈哈对我们有美食专家
Lucia: Haha, yes, we have a food expert.
Tasha: 哎等一下别再扫了
Tasha: Hey, wait a second, don't scan it yet.
Tasha: 还还可以用下一个券呢
Tasha: We can still use the next coupon.
Alice: 还没到500呢
Alice: We haven't reached 500 yet.
Tasha: 不用到500
Tasha: No need to reach 500.
Alice:那你多少
Alice: So how much?
Tasha: 满20 哈哈哈
Tasha: Just reach 20, hahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈满20满20
Jake: Hahaha, just reach 20, reach 20.
Alice:来最后一个
Alice: Come on, the last one.
Alice:随便拿几个券
Alice: Just grab a few coupons.
Tasha: 我不确定满多少
Tasha: I'm not sure how much.
Tasha: 我看一下
Tasha: Let me check.
Alice: 你先你先把那个满500的那个10块钱用了
Alice: You first use the 10-dollar coupon for reaching 500.
Jake: 凑到了500
Jake: We've reached 500.
Tasha: 满49和满29哎
Tasha: There's a 49 coupon and a 29 one.
Jake: 先用49的
Jake: Use the 49 one first.
Tasha: 满29的水果券
Tasha: The 29 one is for fruits.
Jake: 先用49的
Jake: Use the 49 one first.
Tasha: 这个是用的什么券
Tasha: What coupon are we using?
Shure:  哎差不多差不多
Shure: Oh, it's almost there.
Shure:  无所谓无所谓
Shure: It doesn't matter.
Tasha: 这是水果卷
Tasha: This is a fruit coupon.
Katrina: 要吗
Katrina: Do we need it?
Jake: 他一天能扫这么多
Jake: He can scan so many in a day.
Tasha: 还有一个海鲜券
Tasha: There's still a seafood coupon.
Shure:  给杨老板省了不到一新币
Shure: Saved Jake less than one dollar.
Alice:有海鲜吗
Alice: Do we have any seafood?
Katrina: 海鲜是不是扫完了
Katrina: Is the seafood already scanned?
Alice:我们买海鲜了吗
Alice: Did we buy seafood?
Katrina:  没有买海鲜
Katrina: We didn't buy any seafood.
Jake: 一新币很重要的
Jake: One dollar is important.
Tasha: 那好吧那就扫不完了
Tasha: Alright, then we can't scan it all.
Jake: 一新币可以
Jake: One dollar is fine.
Lucia: 虾虾虾滑算海鲜吗
Lucia: Does shrimp count as seafood?
Shure:  可口可乐能买吗
Shure: Can we buy Coca-Cola?
Jake: 买不了哈哈哈
Jake: No, we can't, hahaha.
Tasha: 虾滑算海鲜吗
Tasha: Does shrimp count as seafood?
Alice:算
Alice: Yes, it does.
Tasha: 完了那部分被我
Tasha: Oh no, then that part was...
Tasha: 们扫掉了
Tasha: We swept it away.
Shure:  没事的没事的
Shure: It's okay, it's okay.
Katrina: 算了吧
Katrina: Forget it.
Shure:  就这样吧
Shure: Just leave it like that.
Katrina: 买了1,000块钱
Katrina: Bought it for 1,000 bucks.
Jake: 1新币能干嘛呢
Jake: What can you do with 1 SGD?
Katrina:  省十块也没有
Katrina: Not even saving 10 bucks.
Tasha: 好吧那扫吧
Tasha: Alright, then scan it.
Katrina:  那就只有这一个券是吗
Katrina: So, there's only this coupon, right?
Tasha: 这个是不是扫过了
Tasha: Has this been scanned?
Alice:我这个扫了吗
Alice: Did I scan this one?
Tasha: 坐公交或许
Tasha: Maybe you can take the bus.
Jake: 坐不了哈哈
Jake: Can't even do that, haha.
Katrina:  这两个扫了
Katrina: These two have been scanned.
Katrina: 这个我忘了
Katrina: I forgot about this one.
Katrina:  这个午餐肉扫了吗
Katrina: Has this luncheon meat been scanned?
Alice:这还没扫
Alice: This one hasn't been scanned yet.
Jake: 呃得一块七
Jake: Uh, it's 1.7.
Shure:  哎呀呀呀
Shure: Oh, no no no.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Shure:  你又加了一个
Shure: You added another one.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Shure:  那什么你刚才不小心加了一个
Shure: You accidentally added one just now.
Katrina:  那个但是他是这个吗
Katrina: But was it this one?
Tasha: 这个吗
Tasha: This one?
Katrina:  他们那边公交路上
Katrina: Over there, on the bus route.
Shure:  没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Shure:  不是不是
Katrina: 这个这个
Katrina: This one, this one.
Jake: 不知道耶
Jake: I don't know.
Katrina:  这没扫吧
Katrina: This hasn't been scanned, right?
Jake: 可能
Jake: Maybe.
小薇这个
Tasha: This one.
Jake: 国内也是两块钱
Jake: It's also 2 RMB back home.
Katrina: 这没扫没扫
Katrina: This hasn't been scanned, hasn't been scanned.
Jake: 没错没错
Jake: Yes, yes.
Jake: 这边也是两
Jake: It's 2 here as well.
Jake: 那边也两块钱
Jake: And 2 over there too.
Jake: 国内刷支付宝只要这
Jake: With Alipay back home, it's only this.
Alice: 感觉不能再装了
Alice: Feels like we can't fit anymore.
Alice:这个装巨多饮料
Alice: This one is packed with a lot of drinks.
Tasha: 这个扫过了是吧
Tasha: This one is scanned, right?
Alice: 扫过了这都是扫过的
Alice: Yeah, it's all scanned.
Katrina:  桌上都是扫过的
Katrina: Everything on the table is scanned.
Shure:  哎呦sorry sorry
Shure: Oh, sorry, sorry.
Shure:  不好意思
Shure: My bad.
Tasha: 这个真的还能装沉的吗
Tasha: Can this one really hold the weight?
Tasha: 小瓶子放进去OK
Tasha: Put the small bottle in, it's fine.
Tasha: 主要是这个重量
Tasha: The main thing is the weight.
Tasha: 这里面好像饮料比较多
Tasha: Looks like there are more drinks in here.
Tasha: 别别别压他了别压他了
Tasha: Don't press down on it, don't press down on it.
Tasha: 好了万一托着底抱托着底抱
Tasha: Okay, hold the bottom just in case, hold the bottom.
Tasha: 能扎上吗
Tasha: Can we tie it up?
Jake: 我来扎我来扎
Jake: I'll tie it, I'll tie it.
Lucia: 这个这把这个拿起来
Lucia: Take this one up.
Lucia: 然后把这个放在这扎
Lucia: And then tie this one here.
Lucia: 可能好扎一些
Lucia: It might be easier to tie.
Jake: 哎呦进不去
Jake: Oh no, it won't go in.
Shure:  妈呀这个一会
Shure: Oh man, this is gonna...
Lucia: 这个好重
Lucia: This is really heavy.
Katrina: 这水自带的吧
Katrina: Did this water come with it?
Jake: 分两袋吧
Jake: Let's split it into two bags.
Tasha: 分两车吧
Tasha: Let's split it into two carts.
Jake: 再来辆车
Jake: Get another cart.
Jake: 我来开车
Jake: I'll drive.
Jake: 我去开车
Jake: I'm going to drive.
Lucia: 这个这个袋子有点太重了
Lucia: This bag is a bit too heavy.
Lucia: 一个可能撑不住
Lucia: One might not hold it.
Tasha: 我感觉应该分散一点吧
Tasha: I think we should spread it out a bit.
Shure: 这撑不住的
Shure: This won't hold up.
Shure:  这个太太那什么了
Shure: This is too, too much.
Lucia: 就是得抱着
Lucia: We need to hold it.
Lucia: 拿两瓶饮料重要出来
Lucia: Take two bottles out.
Lucia: 然后放到这里面可以吗
Lucia: And put them in here, okay?
Lucia: 这个够重这重吗
Lucia: Is this heavy enough?
Alice:这个倒是不重
Alice: This one isn't heavy.
Lucia: 那就把这放上 要不然的话 咦 sorry
Lucia: Then put this one on. Otherwise... oh, sorry.
Shure:  不要把一个鸡蛋装在同一个篮子里哦
Shure: Don't put all your eggs in one basket.
Katrina:  放多个篮子了
Katrina: Put them in multiple baskets.
Tasha: 可以
Tasha: That's fine.
Tasha: 拿一些这种轻的东西放在这个袋子里
Tasha: Put some of these light things in this bag.
Lucia: 然后
Lucia: And then...
Katrina: 这蓝莓好大呀
Katrina: These blueberries are so big.
Alice:盐火锅底料
Alice: Salt hot pot base.
Jake: 车到了
Jake: The car is here.
Lucia: 要要不要再拿瓶饮料出来
Lucia: Do we need to take another bottle of drink out?
Lucia: 那个这个
Lucia: This one, this one.
Lucia: 这个现在重吗
Lucia: Is this heavy now?
Alice: 这个不重
Alice: This isn't heavy.
Lucia: 我们要是还有别的那还得有别的袋子
Lucia: If we have more, we'll need another bag.
Lucia: 那这个就放这吧
Lucia: Let's just leave this here.
Katrina:  他没有布袋子吗
Katrina: Doesn't he have a cloth bag?
Katrina:  只有这种袋子
Katrina: Only this kind of bag?
Shure: 没有
Shure: No.
Tasha: 能不能租个推车回去
Tasha: Can we rent a cart to take it back?
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 谢谢会不会有点重啊
Lucia: Thanks, is it too heavy?
Tasha: 你不会在思考这个可行性吧
Tasha: Are you really thinking about the feasibility of this?
Jake: 确实
Jake: Indeed.
Tasha: 不可以
Tasha: No, we can't.
Jake: 哎呦sorry不好意思不好意思
Jake: Oh, sorry, my bad, my bad.
Katrina: OK 啦这水不是的吧
Katrina: OK, this water isn't for that, right?
Lucia: 这都是一些怕压的东西
Lucia: These are all fragile items.
Shure:  现在咱把他们放到最上面吧
Shure: Let's put them on top now.
Lucia: 这个这个还行估计这个先放这里边
Lucia: This one is okay, let's put this one here first.
Lucia: 像草莓鸡蛋这种这种
Lucia: Like strawberries and eggs, these kinds of things.
Jake: 那上哪租你知道吗
Jake: Do you know where to rent one?
Alice: 这个可以放这个
Alice: This one can go here.
Jake: 不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Tasha: 哪个
Tasha: Which one?
Alice:这
Alice: This one.
Lucia: 哎这俩是一块的
Lucia: Oh, these two go together.
Jake: 好吧
Jake: Alright.
Alice:对这俩是一块
Alice: Yes, these two go together.
Alice:这是送的
Alice: This is a gift.
Tasha: 有车吗
Tasha: Is there a car?
Tasha: 你摄像头呢
Tasha: Where's your camera?
Shure:  有吧
Shure: I guess so.
Jake: 呃换一个
Jake: Uh, change it.
Jake: 这个没电了
Jake: This one's out of battery.
Jake: 这些先放车里吧
Jake: 头掉了
Jake: 哎呀来吧
Katrina: 来吧放这去
Alice:有点记不住
Alice:算了不强求
Alice:就这样吧
Lucia: 我们还有袋子吗
Lucia: 没有的话应该也能装下
Lucia: 对要不把这个
Lucia: 我这底下已经放了一个饮料了
Lucia: 还能压吗
Shure:  没事你压
Katrina: 还有维c
Lucia: 这个袋子是不是太重了
Lucia: 这样的话
Shure: 没事
Katrina:  付钱喽
Shure:  付钱喽
Alice:付钱喽
Jake: 要买
Tasha: 9块钱要买厨房湿巾吗
Tasha: Do we really need to spend 9 bucks on kitchen wipes?
Shure:  来拿着
Shure: Here, take it.
Katrina:  来吧
Katrina: Sure, let's do it.
Tasha: 因为不是吃火锅吗
Tasha: Because we’re having hotpot, right?
Shure:  好
Shure: Alright.
Shure:  拿着
Shure: Take it.
Jake: 行
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 9块钱好像
Tasha: It seems like it's 9 bucks.
Tasha: 啊9.9
Tasha: Oh, 9.9.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Let's go.
Alice:搁这里面
Alice: Put it in here.
Tasha: 我真的还有这么多钱吗
Tasha: Do I really have that much money left?
Shure:  我相信你是个大富婆
Shure: I believe you're a rich lady.
Tasha: 你信错了
Tasha: You’re mistaken.
Lucia: 这个这个能放到这吗
Lucia: Can this go here?
Katrina: 拿着
Katrina: Hold this.
Shure:  这个
Shure: This one.
Shure:  鸡蛋放这先
Shure: Put the eggs here first.
Lucia: 先这样吧
Lucia: Let's start with this.
Lucia: 然后我们一会可以再看怎么样
Lucia: Then we can see how it goes later.
Lucia: 整理一下好
Lucia: Let's tidy up a bit.
Shure:  我天啊
Shure: Oh my god.
Lucia: 这还有有包葱
Lucia: There's a pack of green onions here.
Jake: 哼
Jake: Hmph.
Tasha:这结了吗
Tasha: Is this done?
Lucia: 这是蒜
Lucia: This is garlic.
Alice: 这不是葱吗
Alice: Isn't this green onion?
Lucia: 这不是大蒜苗吗
Lucia: Isn't this garlic sprouts?
Tasha: 完了
Tasha: Oh no.
Alice:蒜苗一样的一样的
Alice: Garlic sprouts, same thing.
Alice:无所谓
Alice: Doesn't matter.
Shure:  谁不是谁把葱
Shure: Who brought the green onions?
Shure:  哎呀哈哈
Shure: Oh my, haha.
Lucia: 再买一个吧
Lucia: Let's buy another one.
Tasha: 可以可以买
Tasha: Yeah, we can buy it.
Lucia: 啊不是我觉得他是葱
Lucia: Ah, no, I think it's green onion.
Lucia: 他是葱同志们要不要看一眼
Lucia: It's green onion, guys, want to take a look?
Tasha: 蒜苗就是蒜苗
Tasha: Garlic sprouts are garlic sprouts.
Shure:  蒜苗就是蒜苗
Shure: Garlic sprouts are garlic sprouts.
Tasha: 这这是蒜苗呀
Tasha: This is garlic sprouts.
Lucia: 这是蒜苗吗
Lucia: Is this garlic sprouts?
Alice:是是蒜苗
Alice: Yes, it's garlic sprouts.
是蒜这是一个叠被子
Narrator: It's garlic, this is a folded quilt.
Shure:  完全不是一个味
Shure: Completely different taste.
Tasha: 才买个葱
Tasha: Just buy green onions.
Katrina: 啊好的
Katrina: Ah, okay.
Alice: 无所谓把它当葱用吧
Alice: Doesn't matter, use it like green onions.
Alice:也可以
Alice: It's fine.
Shure:  咱俩完全不是一个味啊
Shure: We totally have different tastes.
Tasha: 不是一个味啊
Tasha: Different tastes.
Shure:  蒜苗是蒜的味
Shure: Garlic sprouts taste like garlic.
Lucia: 我刚才拿起来突然一看
Lucia: I just picked it up and suddenly saw...
Lucia: 这是到底是什么东西
Lucia: What is this exactly?
Shure:  那张那张账单在谁那呢
Shure: Where's that receipt?
Jake: 可以啊
Jake: Got it.
Katrina:  就两个呀
Katrina: Just two, right?
Shure:  还有一张账单啊
Shure: There’s another receipt.
Katrina:  第一个没打是不是
Katrina: The first one didn’t print, right?
Tasha: 第一个打了
Tasha: The first one rang.
Tasha: 谁拿着呢
Tasha: Who has it?
Jake: 我我没拿呀
Jake: I don't have it.
Shure:  忘忘塞到哪了
Shure: Forgot where you put it?
Jake: 我可能没拿吧
Jake: I probably didn't take it.
Tasha: 我没拿呀
Tasha: I don't have it.
Jake: 我应该没拿
Jake: I think I didn't take it.
Tasha: 我应该没拿呀
Tasha: I think I didn't take it.
Jake: 那可能就是拿了吧
Jake: Then maybe we did take it.
Alice: 这不两条吗
Alice: Aren't there two?
Tasha: 葱要不要再买一个
Tasha: Should we buy another green onion?
Jake: 两条吗我去
Jake: There are two? Oh no.
Lucia: 哎那怎么又变成两条了
Lucia: Wait, how did it become two?
Lucia: 还有一条
Lucia: There's one more.
Tasha:葱我去拿吧
Tasha: I'll go get the green onion.
Shure: 本来就两条
Shure: There were always two.
Jake: 应该连起来
Jake: They should be together.
Lucia: 本来就两条
Lucia: There were always two.
Alice:哎哎哎去那边葱
Alice: Hey, hey, go over there for the green onion.
Jake: 订一下
Jake: Place an order.
Alice:有机葱比较贵
Alice: Organic green onions are more expensive.
Alice: 啊但我们后面预算不够怎么办啊
Alice: Ah, but what do we do if we go over budget?
Tasha: 说如果预算够的话还能去那个玩了
Tasha: They said if we have enough budget, we can still go to that place.
Alice:这也太多了
Alice: This is too much.
Tasha: 这也太大了
Tasha: This is too big.
Alice:啊好烫啊
Alice: Ah, it's so hot.
Tasha: 我这也好烫
Tasha: It's so hot here too.
Alice:其实3个葱也不多
Alice: Actually, three green onions aren't too much.
Tasha: 行了你要的话我觉得
Tasha: Fine, if you want, I think...
Alice:走吧
Alice: Let's go.
Lucia: 这个葱11块8 我觉得
Lucia: This green onion is 11.8. I think...
Alice: 这是一斤啊
Alice: This is a pound?
Tasha: 有没有葱姜蒜组合呀
Tasha: Is there a combo of green onion, ginger, and garlic?
Tasha: 葱姜蒜组合在哪里啊
Tasha: Where's the green onion, ginger, and garlic combo?
Alice: 很小
Alice: It's very small.
Tasha: 要不这个吧
Tasha: How about this one?
Alice:这个够用吗
Alice: Is this enough?
Tasha: 够用了呀
Tasha: It's enough.
Shure: 还有7毫的
Shure: There's also 7 milliliters.
Alice:多少钱啊
Alice: How much is it?
Tasha: 两块8 嗯
Tasha: Two dollars and eighty cents, hmm.
Alice:拿两个吧
Alice: Let's get two.
Lucia: 不过这种事确实挺多的
Lucia: But this kind of thing happens a lot.
Tasha: 那我想要这个好看的
Tasha: Then I want this pretty one.
Tasha: 我还想要一个绿的
Tasha: I also want a green one.
Tasha: 那就拿这两个吧
Tasha: Okay, let's get these two.
Alice:小米辣我们有吗
Alice: Do we have chili peppers?
Tasha: 呃要单独的小米辣吗
Tasha: Uh, do you mean individual chili peppers?
Alice:啊有有都行
Alice: Ah, either way is fine.
Lucia: 不是火锅底料
Lucia: Not the hot pot base.
Tasha: 嗯买过了
Tasha: Hmm, we already bought it.
Alice: 麻酱
Alice: Sesame paste.
Alice:呃不对就是那个底料里面会有
Alice: Uh no, it's in the base.
Alice: 如果没有人提话说明没有人爱吃
Alice: If no one mentions it, it means no one likes it.
Alice:好烫啊烫的我
Alice: It's so hot, it's burning me.
Jake: American is the best
Jake: American is the best.
Alice:结一下吧
Alice: Let's settle the bill.
Alice:结吧结吧
Alice: Let's settle it.
Lucia: 会翻译成这样吗
Lucia: Will it translate like this?
Alice: 这怎么拿回去啊
Alice: How do we take this back?
Katrina:  一人一个
Katrina: One for each person.
Tasha: 他是怎么支付的
Tasha: How did he pay?
Tasha: 呀我就想知道
Tasha: Yeah, I just want to know.
Alice:直接开始结账
Alice: Just start the checkout.
Lucia: 大家喜欢花最低的价格买东西
Lucia: Everyone likes to buy things at the lowest price.
Tasha: 是啊
Tasha: Yeah.
Alice:扫描一下
Alice: Scan it.
Katrina:  哈
Katrina: Ha.
Tasha: 我们最后一天会去哪里玩啊
Tasha: Where will we go on our last day?
Tasha: 如果还有经费会去环球影城玩吗
Tasha: If we have the budget, will we go to Universal Studios?
Tasha: 但是如果没有经费的话可能就不了吧
Tasha: But if we don't have the budget, maybe not.
Tasha: 给老板
Tasha: For the boss.
Alice: 给老板
Alice: For the boss.
Katrina:  咦
Katrina: Eh.
Shure:  啊这很有品啊
Shure: Ah, this is quite tasteful.
Katrina:  这说明我
Katrina: That means I...
Shure:  原来你也喜欢这一口嗯
Shure: So you like this too, huh?
Katrina:  这是什么
Katrina: What is this?
Tasha: 我帮你贴上吗
Tasha: Should I stick it on for you?
Jake: 好啊哈哈哈
Jake: Sure, haha.
Jake: 你就你就
Jake: You just, you just...
Jake: 你就欠这一刀
Jake: You just owe one more cut.
Jake: 手带现在这个长度很好
Jake: The length of the wristband is perfect now.
Jake: 就这样
Jake: Just like this.
Shure:  走吧
Shure: Let's go.
Alice:走吧
Alice: Let's go.
Shure:  go
Shure: Go.
Jake: 走
Jake: Let's go.
Alice:我的天呐
Alice: Oh my god.
Tasha: 那芋头还有蛋挞皮
Tasha: So there's taro and egg tart crusts.
Tasha: 还有刚刚说的薄荷
Tasha: And then the mint we just talked about.
Tasha: 还有你们那个好像还有两个材料
Tasha: And you guys seem to have two more ingredients.
Tasha: 就从网上买的
Tasha: Just bought them online.
Alice:什么美文纸
Alice: What beautiful paper?
Katrina:  嗯那偏文具类的我上网买
Katrina: Hmm, for stationery stuff, I buy online.
Katrina:  嗯或者是我看看外送有没有
Katrina: Hmm, or I check if there's delivery available.
Katrina: 因为我们在设计地球的
Katrina: Because we're designing the Earth.
Katrina: 那个海报啊什么都是肯定上网买的啊
Katrina: The posters and stuff are definitely bought online.
Katrina:  啊什么东西上网买
Katrina: Ah, what stuff to buy online?
Katrina: 感觉会漂亮一点
Katrina: Feels like it would look prettier.
Tasha: 肯定也会在网上买的吧
Tasha: Definitely bought online too, right?
Tasha: 我觉得啊
Tasha: I think so.
Tasha: 海报什么东西
Tasha: Posters and stuff.
Alice:我的天呐啊
Alice: Oh my god.
Jake: 能租车
Jake: We can rent a car.
Lucia: 这叫我们怎么拿出去啊
Lucia: How do we take it out?
Shure:  杨老板先把车打上吧
Shure: Jake, start the car first.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Got it.
Alice:啊呀妈呀
Alice: Oh my gosh.
Lucia: 这每感觉每个袋子都挺重的
Lucia: Every bag feels heavy.
Alice:都好沉啊
Alice: They're all so heavy.
Jake: 我们就直接打车了
Jake: We'll just take a cab.
Jake: 不再买点咖啡什么的
Jake: Not buying coffee or anything?
Jake: 不了吧
Jake: No, right?
Jake: 现在有点晚了
Jake: It's a bit late now.
Tasha: 不用喝了
Tasha: No need to drink it.
Jake: 是吧
Jake: Right?
Alice:都是
Alice: Yeah, all of it.
Katrina:  我们直接去吃饭是吗
Katrina: We're going straight to eat, right?
Tasha: 对吃什么呢
Tasha: Yeah, what to eat?
Shure:  你们拎着这么多东西
Shure: You guys are carrying so much stuff.
Alice: 这地能有放的吗
Alice: Is there space to put it down here?
Shure:  东西
Shure: Stuff...
Jake: 确实啊
Jake: Yeah, indeed.
Shure: 肯定得回趟家
Shure: We definitely need to go home first.
Lucia: 拿这么多东西去吃饭有点
Lucia: Bringing so much stuff to eat out is a bit...
Shure:  要不就吃饭
Shure: How about we just eat?
Tasha: 要不就点外卖吧
Tasha: Or let's just order takeout.
Katrina: 吃房榴莲
Katrina: Eat room durian.
Jake: 行回去点外卖吧
Jake: Okay, let's go home and order takeout.
Jake: 可以吧
Jake: Is that alright?
Lucia: 都可以一起出去也可以
Lucia: We can all go out together too.
Jake: 在这是就是有冻的东西对吧
Jake: The thing is, we have frozen stuff here, right?
Shure:  是吧而且还有要要冻的东西
Shure: Right, and we have things that need to stay frozen.
Jake: 是吧是有冷冻的
Jake: Right, we have frozen stuff.
Jake: 冷冻的东西
Jake: Frozen stuff.
Shure:  然后大家看一眼那个哪些是冷冻
Shure: Let's everyone check which ones need to be frozen.
Shure:  哪些是冷藏
Shure: And which ones need to be refrigerated.
Katrina:  放一会吧
Katrina: Let's leave them for a while.
Shure:  比如说那毛肚什么的
Shure: For example, the tripe.
Shure:  他就是说让0-4度
Shure: It needs to be kept at 0-4 degrees.
Tasha: 你要放下来吗
Tasha: Do you want to put it down?
Jake: 啊再来一辆车你要不
Jake: Do you want another car?
Shure:  他只能到这儿了
Shure: He can only go this far.
Tasha: 他只能到这儿了
Tasha: He can only go this far.
Shure:  爸爸只能送你到这儿了
Shure: Dad can only take you this far.
Shure:  未来的路要靠你自己了
Shure: The rest of the way, you'll have to go on your own.
Lucia: 妈耶
Lucia: Oh my.
Shure:  听到了吗
Shure: Did you hear that?
Shure:  那是你的朗姆的声音
Shure: That's the sound of your rum.
Shure:  他现在向你发出回应
Shure: It's responding to you now.
Alice:有点沉这个给我吧
Alice: It's a bit heavy, let me take it.
Katrina:  这样我们的冰箱就满了
Katrina: This way our fridge will be full.
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes.
Lucia: 冰箱能不能放下呀
Lucia: Can the fridge hold all this?
Shure:  你不要把它喝凉了
Shure: Don't let it get cold.
Shure:  哈哈哈全喝光
Shure: Haha, drink it all up.
Jake: 回头
Jake: Later...
Katrina: 草莓也全吃了
Katrina: Eat all the strawberries too.
Jake: 就是这个数据比较重要
Jake: This data is quite important.
Jake: 就是回头你们收拾的时候
Jake: So when you guys clean up later
Jake: 会和超市
Jake: It will be with the supermarket
Jake: 你们的一些行为建立一些联系
Jake: You can establish some connections with your behavior
Jake: 就是比方说你把这东西放到冰箱
Jake: For example, if you put something in the fridge
Jake: 然后他只能找回到你在哪找到的那个
Jake: Then it can only trace back to where you found it
Lucia: 哦那就跟亚马逊那个无人采购超市
Lucia: Oh, like Amazon's cashier-less grocery store
Lucia: 一样的那种感觉
Lucia: That kind of feeling
Jake: 对对对溯源
Jake: Yes, exactly, traceability
Katrina: 溯源啦
Katrina: Traceability!
Jake: 对就是溯源这种rechieve
Jake: Yes, exactly, this kind of retrieve
Jake: 特厉害你去不
Jake: It's very powerful, right?
Shure:  你们上链的吗
Shure: Are you guys on the blockchain?
Shure:  呵呵
Shure: Haha
Katrina:  当心哦
Katrina: Be careful
Katrina:  谢谢阿莫总
Katrina: Thanks, Amo
Lucia: 阿莫总开了好几个那种
Lucia: Amo opened several of those
Lucia: 那种超市
Lucia: Those kinds of stores
Lucia: 就是你出门不用结账
Lucia: Where you don't need to check out when you leave
Lucia: 他知道你买了什么
Lucia: They know what you bought
Lucia: 然后自动在你的账户里付款
Lucia: And automatically charge your account
Lucia: 就是他根据你的重量
Lucia: Based on the weight
Lucia: 好像就是你放进去然后东西多重
Lucia: Like you put it in and the weight is calculated
Lucia: 对他会精确到多少多少毫克
Lucia: Yes, it can be accurate to a few milligrams
Lucia: 然后呢他就会自动把这钱扣走
Lucia: Then it automatically deducts the money
Lucia: 是超市里
Lucia: Inside the store
Lucia: 就跟我们一样
Lucia: Just like us
Jake:那我要稍微哎
Jake: Then I have to...
Lucia: 就是它有很多摄像头
Lucia: It has a lot of cameras
Lucia: 就是能看到你拿了什么
Lucia: That can see what you took
Alice:超多
Alice: So many
Lucia: 他监测你有没有在货架上拿东西
Lucia: They monitor if you take things off the shelves
Lucia: 包括你进出的时候的各种数据
Lucia: Including various data when you go in and out
Lucia: 反正很神奇的一个东西
Lucia: It's a really amazing thing
Lucia: 不过就是偶尔有算错的可能性
Lucia: But sometimes there can be mistakes
Shure:  那肯定
Shure: Definitely
Shure:  因为每一个我都这么拿
Shure: Because I take each one like this
Lucia: 哎那个好像他也能监测的到
Lucia: Oh, it seems like it can detect that too
Lucia: 呵呵不过有时候是会算错的
Lucia: Haha, but sometimes it does miscalculate
Shure:  我打个雨伞呐
Shure: If I use an umbrella
Shure:  他肯定检测不到了吧
Shure: It definitely can't detect that, right?
Lucia: 去实验一下
Lucia: Let's go experiment.
Jake: 对总之比0元购强
Jake: Yeah, it's better than getting it for free.
Jake: 就是这是他的玻璃
Jake: This is his glass.
Jake:玻璃好歹还在人抢
Jake: At least people are fighting for the glass.
Jake: 好歹还算算法错误
Jake: At least it's just an algorithm error.
Shure:  就是我就爱打伞
Shure: I just love using an umbrella.
Shure:  在室内
Shure: Indoors.
Shure:  对
Shure: Right.
Shure:  是吧
Shure: Isn't it?
Jake: 他有可能是商品上面贴条了
Jake: Maybe he has a tag on the product.
Jake: 贴无线电
Jake: A radio tag.
Jake: 他还有6分钟到
Jake: He still has 6 minutes left.
Alice:开始往下走吧
Alice: Let's start heading down.
Jake: 往上走好像是
Jake: Heading up, I think.
Jake:这是往上走对吧
Jake: This is going up, right?
Katrina:  往下吧
Katrina: Let's go down.
Alice:我们不是二楼吗
Alice: Aren't we on the second floor?
Alice:我们是这样上来的呀
Alice: We came up this way.
Jake:哦这么回事啊
Jake: Oh, that's what it is.
Alice: 一进门一进门不是有个升的电梯
Alice: When you enter, isn't there an elevator that goes up?
Jake: 有道理
Jake: Makes sense.
Jake: 因为这地方太像地下了
Jake: Because this place feels like a basement.
Alice: 有点阴森有点不热闹
Alice: It's a bit eerie and not lively.
Shure:  我在搞地下音乐
Shure: I'm into underground music.
Jake: 走吧
Jake: Let's go.
Alice:有点
Alice: A bit.
Katrina:  这我来吧
Katrina: I'll take this.
Katrina: 因为我有一个鸡蛋
Katrina: Because I have an egg.
Alice: 没事这个不沉
Alice: It's fine, this isn't heavy.
Katrina:  你看
Katrina: Look.
Katrina:  没事我就一点点都没
Katrina: It's fine, I don't mind at all.
Tasha: 你你一个人拎两个
Tasha: You can carry two on your own?
Katrina: 就主要是那个酒比较多的那个
Katrina: The one with more wine is the main issue.
Jake: 你你你这么厉害吗
Jake: Are you that strong?
Alice: 而且饮料多的比较沉
Alice: And the one with more drinks is heavier.
Alice: 你再一人掂一掂
Alice: You should each carry one.
Jake: 这才对嘛
Jake: That's more like it.
Jake: 走吧
Jake: Let's go.
Shure:  您是
Shure: You are...
Katrina: 没事你你
Katrina: It's fine, you, you...
Katrina: 真的可以这样利用老板吗
Katrina: Can we really use the boss like this?
Shure:  天啊
Shure: Oh my god.
Jake:这样比较平衡
Jake: This way it's more balanced.
Shure:  这样比较这厨房湿巾一定很沉吧
Shure: This way, these kitchen wipes must be really heavy.
Tasha: 哈哈哈这这鸡蛋也很沉吧
Tasha: Hahaha, these eggs must be heavy too.
Lucia: 哈哈这鸡蛋很宝贵
Lucia: Haha, these eggs are precious.
Shure:  对没事
Shure: Yeah, it's fine.
Katrina:  我需要专人护送
Katrina: I need a special escort.
Shure:  我只送到你们到门口
Shure: I'll just take you to the door.
Shure:  好吧
Shure: Okay.
Jake: 好
Jake: Alright.
Jake: 我这线是掉了吗
Jake: Did my cable fall?
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No.
Tasha: 老板
Tasha: Boss.
Tasha: 老板拎着最多的东西
Tasha: The boss is carrying the most stuff.
Lucia: 真的真的
Lucia: Really, really.
Lucia: 要不要帮你安上
Lucia: Do you want help to put it back?
Jake:好啊好啊
Jake: Sure, sure.
Lucia: 稍等一下
Lucia: Just a moment.
Lucia: 你别走
Lucia: Don't move.
Jake: OK了开始开动
Jake: Okay, let's get started.
Katrina: connected
Katrina: Connected.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈好搞笑啊
Alice: Hahahahaha, this is so funny.
Shure:  这是老板吗
Shure: Is this the boss?
Shure:  我们是被一个AI领导的一群人类
Shure: We're led by an AI and a group of humans.
Shure:  是吗
Shure: Right?
Tasha: 呃重吗我跟你一起拎
Tasha: Uh, is it heavy? I'll carry it with you.
Alice:不用不用这个就一个兜啊
Alice: No, no, it's just one bag.
Jake: 就我我头上的和我眼前的
Jake: It's just the one on my head and in front of me.
Shure: 那个鸡蛋保护起来一定很累
Shure: Protecting those eggs must be tiring.
Jake: 就是我的接收设备
Jake: It's my receiving device.
Katrina: 不行你没有这个资格
Katrina: No, you don't have the qualification.
Jake: 我全靠他来支撑我
Jake: I rely on it to support me.
Jake: 哈哈哈一些行为
Jake: Hahaha, some actions.
Lucia: 这个故事开始向恐怖片方向发展了
Lucia: This story is starting to turn into a horror movie.
Shure:  蛋
Shure: Egg.
Katrina:  蛋蛋
Katrina: Egg, egg.
Tasha: 这颗葱拐到你的脚了
Tasha: This scallion twisted to your foot.
Tasha: 我帮你拿着
Tasha: Let me hold it for you.
Shure:  你要把鼻也夹进去
Shure: You need to clamp your nose too.
Jake:啊会吗谢谢
Jake: Ah really? Thank you.
Katrina: 所以他们要
Katrina: So they need to...
Jake: 所以很重要
Jake: So it's very important.
Katrina: 所以你们最后买葱了吗
Katrina: So did you guys end up buying the green onions?
Jake: 哈哈哈所以呢
Jake: Hahaha, so what?
Jake:哈哈哈critical
Jake: Hahaha, critical.
Alice:买了买了
Alice: Yeah, we bought them.
Shure:  买了这么大一节葱白
Shure: We bought a huge piece of the white part.
Alice:不是这还是蒜苗
Alice: No, that's garlic sprouts.
Alice:我们的葱在那个篮里面呢
Alice: Our green onions are in that basket.
Tasha: 买了一个葱姜蒜组合
Tasha: We bought a set with green onions, ginger, and garlic.
Shure:  发明这个的人真是天才
Shure: The person who invented this is a genius.
Jake: 我觉得每人带根线是有点酷啊
Jake: I think everyone carrying a wire is kind of cool.
Shure: 就是
Shure: Exactly.
Jake:你这么一眼看过去
Jake: When you look at it...
Alice:尤其我们这样走在一起
Alice: Especially when we're walking together like this.
Shure: 一会我回程的路上要地铁
Shure: On my way back, I need to take the subway.
Alice:感觉像一个什么组织
Alice: Feels like some kind of organization.
Tasha: 有点像一个神秘组织
Tasha: Kind of like a secret organization.
Shure: 这个数据要录下来吗
Shure: Do we need to record this data?
Jake: 可以录
Jake: We can record it.
Shure:  OK
Shure: OK.
Tasha: 尤其这个眼镜还发光的感觉
Tasha: Especially with these glasses that seem to glow.
Katrina: 但他地铁要差不多两个小时
Katrina: But the subway takes almost two hours.
Jake:你地铁你地铁
Jake: Your subway, your subway.
Tasha: 大家都带同一款
Tasha: Everyone's wearing the same model.
Jake: 进个进一下出一下得了
Jake: Just go in and out quickly.
Jake: 你就进去吧
Jake: Just go in.
Jake: 进去然后就关掉
Jake: Go in and then turn it off.
Jake: 然后主要是你看你答辩
Jake: The main thing is, look at your defense.
Jake:哈哈哈你答辩
Jake: Hahaha, your defense.
Shure:  真的真的好录吗
Shure: Really, is it easy to record?
Shure:  方便吗方便哎
Shure: Is it convenient?
Jake:方便
Jake: Convenient.
Jake: 你问Andy对吧你的老师Andy
Jake: You ask Andy, right? Your teacher Andy.
Shure:  说我在进行一个奇怪的项目
Shure: I'll tell him I'm working on a strange project.
Jake: 对你问Andy想不想进数据集
Jake: Yeah, ask Andy if he wants to join the dataset.
Jake: 想不想被人研究研究
Jake: Does he want to be studied?
Shure:  安妮好像英国人会对这
Shure: Annie, being British, might be more sensitive about this.
Shure:  隐私方面更敏感一些吧
Shure: More sensitive about privacy, right?
Lucia: 我们往哪走啊
Lucia: Where are we going?
Lucia: 是这边吗
Lucia: Is it this way?
Alice: 都可以出去
Alice: We can go out either way.
Tasha: 这边是我们刚刚
Tasha: This way is where we just...
Tasha: 最近的那个
Tasha: The nearest one.
Katrina:  嗯不不不
Katrina: Um, no, no, no.
Alice:这个门这个门
Alice: This door, this door.
Alice:都一样
Alice: They're all the same.
Lucia: yes yes
Lucia: Yes, yes.
Jake: 这是探路去了
Jake: They're scouting the way.
Jake: 帮我接个电话
Jake: Answer the phone for me.
Shure:  要不我送你们到这我就先溜了
Shure: How about I drop you off here and then I'll leave.
Shure:  走吧再见
Shure: Let's go, bye.
Katrina: 拜拜
Katrina: Bye-bye.
Jake: 哎我想挠头我靠
Jake: Oh, I want to scratch my head, damn it.
Jake: 拜拜明天见
Jake: Bye-bye, see you tomorrow.
Jake: 喂你好
Jake: Hello, hi.
Shure:  明天见今晚不要想我哦
Shure: See you tomorrow, don't miss me tonight.
Shure: 希望不要想我哦
Shure: Hopefully, you won't miss me.
Katrina: 希望你答辩顺利哦
Katrina: Hope your defense goes well.
Katrina:  对你就到这了
Katrina: Yeah, this is your stop.
Shure:  对我就到这了
Shure: Yeah, this is my stop.
Shure:  呃所以你不能只拎一包湿巾
Shure: Uh, so you can't just carry one pack of wet wipes.
Jake: 呃呃我找找你吧
Jake: Uh, uh, I'll find you.
Jake: 我按照定位找你吧
Jake: I'll find you based on the location.
Jake: 你到了对吧
Jake: You've arrived, right?
Shure:  所以你不能只拎一包湿巾了
Shure: So you can't just carry one pack of wet wipes.
Shure:  拜拜
Shure: Bye.
Jake: 哎哎拜拜拜拜
Jake: Hey, hey, bye-bye.
Tasha: 无语哈哈哈
Tasha: Speechless, hahaha.
Alice: 我们这能放下吗
Alice: Can we put it here?
Lucia: 同想问
Lucia: I was wondering the same.
Alice:可以吧
Alice: Should be fine.
Katrina: 放后备箱
Katrina: Put it in the trunk.
Jake: 好像说在那个地方
Jake: It seems to be in that place.
Jake: 你看你看是在
Jake: Look, look, it's at...
Alice: 嗯是这个门出去
Alice: Yeah, go out through this door.
Jake: 走吧
Jake: Let's go.
Jake: 走吧走吧
Jake: Let's go, let's go.
Alice: 我们刚刚下车的地
Alice: Where we just got off the car.
Jake: 那你帮我导个航
Jake: Can you help me with the navigation?
Jake: 好谢谢你
Jake: Okay, thank you.
Jake: 谢谢您
Jake: Thank you.
Jake: 哎呦
Jake: Oh!
Lucia: 没有那袋重
Lucia: Not as heavy as that bag.
Katrina:  谢谢谢谢
Katrina: Thanks, thanks.
Jake: 这个很重要这个很重要这个
Jake: This is very important, very important.
Jake: 这个哎可以谢谢谢谢
Jake: This one, oh, okay, thanks, thanks.
Alice:好了不用走了就在这
Alice: Alright, no need to move, just stay here.
Katrina:  他能进来吗
Katrina: Can he come in?
Alice: 是呢
Alice: Yes, he can.
Jake: 他能进来啊
Jake: He can come in?
Jake: 这么厉害
Jake: So impressive.
Katrina:  我就把这个放下了啊
Katrina: I'll just put this down, okay?
Jake: 今天挺暖和的
Jake: It's quite warm today.
Jake: 一点也不冷
Jake: Not cold at all.
Katrina:  新加坡一般多少度啊
Katrina: What's the usual temperature in Singapore?
Jake: 呃 23-31每天
Jake: Uh, 23-31 degrees every day.
Katrina:  这么热一年四季都是吗
Katrina: So hot, all year round?
Jake: 每天都一样
Jake: Every day is the same.
Tasha: 这么热嗯
Tasha: So hot, huh?
Jake: 每天都一样
Jake: Every day is the same.
Jake: 是挺闷的
Jake: It's quite stuffy.
Jake: 但是现在我适应了
Jake: But now I'm used to it.
Jake: 我觉得还好
Jake: I think it's okay.
Jake: 只要中午不出去都还好
Jake: As long as I don't go out at noon, it's fine.
Tasha: 哇你看这个大葱头
Tasha: Wow, look at this big scallion head.
Lucia: 你们是四季如夏吗
Lucia: Is it summer all year round for you guys?
Tasha: 上下两层都是这样子的
Tasha: Both upper and lower layers are like this.
Jake: 对是不是每天都一样
Jake: Yes, isn't every day the same?
Alice:我是不是得
Alice: Should I...
Jake: 赤道2度北纬2度
Jake: 2 degrees north of the equator.
Lucia: 真的好热
Lucia: Really hot.
Lucia: 你知不知道
Lucia: Do you know?
Alice:往那再走一点点
Alice: Move a bit more that way.
Katrina: 路边是不是应该进不来吧
Katrina: Shouldn't they be unable to get in from the roadside?
Tasha: 他不能进来吗
Tasha: He can't come in?
Jake: 到了吗
Jake: Are we there yet?
Alice:不知道能不能过去
Alice: Not sure if we can go over.
Tasha: 让他打电话问他一下吧
Tasha: Let him call and ask.
Jake: 我这个电话我这欠费了
Jake: My phone's out of credit.
Jake: 打不出去
Jake: I can't make any calls.
Alice:哦好像
Alice: Oh, it seems like...
Jake: 他是什么色的
Jake: What color is it?
Alice:他好像停了
Alice: It seems like it stopped.
Alice:别克GL8
Alice: It's a Buick GL8.
Katrina: 棕色
Katrina: Brown.
Jake: 他是要我们走过去吧
Jake: Do we need to walk over there?
Alice:我们应该往前走一点点吧
Alice: We should probably walk a little bit forward.
Jake: 那我们走吧
Jake: Alright, let's go.
Katrina: 都没看到那辆车哎
Katrina: I can't see the car.
Jake: 走哎
Jake: Let's go.
Jake: 我刚刚拿的是这个吗
Jake: Was I holding this just now?
Alice:走吧
Alice: Let's go.
Alice: 球友们刚下车的地方
Alice: The place where the players just got off.
Jake: 这是地铁吗
Jake: Is this the subway?
Alice: 喂您好
Alice: Hello?
Jake: 最前面这一条
Jake: The first line at the front.
Jake: 天上这一条
Jake: The one in the sky.
Alice:呃暂时还没有
Alice: Uh, not yet.
Alice:永和大王
Alice: Yonghe King.
Jake: 奔驰啊是吗呵呵呵
Jake: A Mercedes, huh? Haha.
Alice: 永和大王门口
Alice: In front of the Yonghe King.
Lucia: 永和大王那边
Lucia: Over by the Yonghe King.
Tasha: 门口
Tasha: At the entrance.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Alice:是是那个吗
Alice: Is it that one?
Alice: 我靠哎呀
Alice: Damn, oh no.
Alice:双闪的
Alice: The one with the hazard lights.
Katrina: 啥颜色
Katrina: What color?
Alice:看到有双闪
Alice: I see hazard lights.
Lucia: 哪有哪有
Lucia: Where, where?
Alice: 咋是不是那个呀
Alice: Oh, is it that one?
Jake: 啊我看到了
Jake: Ah, I see it.
Jake: 对对对确实
Jake: Yeah, yeah, for sure.
Alice:我是不是得绕一下
Alice: Should I go around?
Jake: 呃就那边吧
Jake: Uh, just over there.
Jake: 不用绕
Jake: No need to go around.
Alice: 那个那个我们这能出去吧
Alice: Can we get out from here?
Katrina: 我们去
Katrina: Let's go.
Alice:呃好的
Alice: Uh, okay.
Alice:我看见您了
Alice: I see you.
Alice:您是那个FA 503是吧
Alice: You are the FA 503, right?
Alice:好的我们找到了谢谢
Alice: Okay, we found it, thanks.
Lucia: 这个我们是不是可以放后备箱
Lucia: Can we put this in the trunk?
Lucia: 或者之类的
Lucia: Or something like that?
Alice: 后备箱可以打开吗
Alice: Can the trunk be opened?
Tasha: 啊天呐咦
Tasha: Oh my, oh no.
Alice:有点小
Alice: It's a bit small.
Alice:挤一下吧
Alice: Squeeze it in.
Alice:再来一个
Alice: Let's add one more.
Katrina:  鸡蛋我抱着吧
Katrina: I'll hold the eggs.
Katrina:  这不还和鸡蛋放哪了
Katrina: Where else can we put these eggs?
Jake: 谢谢哎呀哎呦
Jake: Thanks, oh, ouch.
Lucia: 小心
Lucia: Be careful.
Katrina:  哎呦哎呦
Katrina: Ouch, ouch.
Katrina:  疼
Katrina: It hurts.
Jake: 好疼
Jake: It really hurts.
Alice:还空出来一个位
Alice: There's still a spot left.
Alice:要不然搁前边吧
Alice: Or we can put it in the front.
Katrina:  放放我身上也行
Katrina: Putting it on me is fine too.
Katrina:  这后面只有两个人
Katrina: There are only two people back here.
Jake: 就放那边吧
Jake: Just put it over there.
Jake: 放那边可以吧
Jake: Is it okay to put it over there?
Jake: 还是放哎呦
Jake: Or put it, ouch.
Jake: 看一眼
Jake: Take a look.
Jake: 好疼好疼啊
Jake: It really hurts a lot.
Jake: 呵呵呵呵摸摸头
Jake: Haha, touch my head.
Jake: 摸摸头
Jake: Touch my head.
Jake: 哎不用不用不用
Jake: Oh no, no, no.
Jake: 它自动的它自动的它自动的自动的
Jake: It's automatic, it's automatic, it's automatic.
Alice:好的给你的
Alice: Okay, here you go.
Jake: 摁了他就以为我们要干什么
Jake: If we press it, they might think we're doing something.
Alice:我们俩坐后边吧
Alice: We'll sit in the back.
Tasha: 行啊
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 啊怎么还订6座呢
Tasha: Why did we book a six-seater?
Jake: 那应该点几座
Jake: How many seats should we book?
Katrina:  那我坐老板位了
Katrina: Then I'll sit in the boss seat.
Lucia: 那我还坐前面吧
Lucia: Then I'll still sit in the front.
Lucia: 如果没有人晕车的话
Lucia: If no one gets car sick.
Alice:来吧baby
Alice: Come on, baby.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Alice:头头头
Alice: Head, head, head.
Jake: 哎呦我去
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Tasha: 好疼
Tasha: It hurts.
Lucia: 哎这个能往后一点吗
Lucia: Hey, can this be pushed back a bit?
Lucia: 啊不我是说这个
Lucia: Ah no, I mean this.
Alice:现在还要录吗
Alice: Do we still need to record now?
Jake: 这个关了吧不
Jake: Let's turn this off, okay?
Jake: 不用录了
Jake: No need to record anymore.
Tasha: 呃现在就关了
Tasha: Uh, turn it off now?
Jake: 现在关了
Jake: Turn it off now.
Jake: 可以这一段
Jake: This part is good.
Jake: 这一段主要没有go Pro
Jake: This part mainly doesn't have GoPro.
Jake: 你每次go Pro贼麻烦
Jake: Every time with the GoPro, it's such a hassle.
Alice:又把我家地址录上去
Alice: I recorded my home address again.